it's all about me that's a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan unscented a
world exclusive interview with the man
behind that kiss Luis rubiales speaks
out on FIFA on the lionesses and his
mother's hunger strike on his family and
on his future why did he kiss Jenny
hermoso will he finally apologize to her
could he should he go to jail for what
happened nothing is off limits in this
jaw-dropping interview that ended with a
surprise and stunning on-air resignation
Luis rubiales one on one and uncensored
[Music]
Luis rubialis why have you agreed to do
this interview with me
hello Pierce I think it's an opportunity
it's an opportunity you are a leader of
opinion A lot of people million people
follow you
and I think that a lot of people
millions of people
have an opinion about me about what
happened and
for me like I tell you it's an
opportunity to to tell what really
happening um to give the truth to the
rest of the people now look it's because
of the legal action that you're now
facing you want to do the rest of the
interview in Spanish and we have a
translator who will translate as we go
um
it's been three weeks today since the
Women's World Cup final
and that was when you planted this kiss
on one of the players
which has turned out to be the most
notorious kiss in history
and it's turned your life upside down
how have the three weeks been for you
for me I have been outside of the
tsunami
Familia but at the same time with my
family I have suffered with my friends I
have suffered
um
and a lot of people have been telling
lies yeah
and with all these lies the truth hasn't
surfaced
do you accept that what you did
with that kiss was wrong
um
of course I have said it from the
beginning I made a mistake
and I apologized in a sincere manner
I was very happy I felt like another
player but being the president of the
association I have apologized
unreservedly that is not the actions of
the president of the association
why did you kiss Jenny Hermosa
it was a mutual act she came towards me
very happy she Lifted Me Up She lifted
me up in the air
when we hit the ground there was a quick
conversation
we were both emotional we congratulated
each other I asked her can I give you a
quick Peck which is normal in our
country I gave her a quick pickado
I think she gave me one or two slaps in
my side she was laughing and that was it
of course no sexual connotation of
anything just a moment of Happiness just
great joy in that moment
so Louis this shows what is going on on
the podium here
and you're picking up quite a few of
these girls you're hugging them you're
kissing most of them
as well but on the cheek
and I was struck by that that it's very
tactile I mean
more than you would expect perhaps from
someone in your position
all the medal celebrations with guys and
girls all those celebrations are mutual
they're normal
a couple of minutes before they Lifted
Me Up amazing Harmony everyone is happy
I think Latin people and it's a cultural
question
tactile it's pretty normal in a Latin
World between guys and girls
if the Spanish men's team had won the
World Cup
would you have interacted with those men
the same way
no doubt about it 100
and also when I was a player there were
many moments where we avoid that
relegation or we got promotion
the problem for many people
is that when you came to Jenny Hermosa
you kissed her you've held her head with
your hands and you pulled it towards you
and you kissed a full on the lips
and many people think that was
completely inappropriate behavior
a lot of people have seen this still
image a lot of people have seen still
images of that or indeed the case which
lasted two tenths of a second it was a
moment of future in fact just before
that Jenny lifted me off the ground she
didn't ask me it was just a moment of
happiness or Fusion
Pierce what you need to also understand
is that she all during this time on the
podium she's holding me she's laughing
your position is
that she lifted you up and that you
asked her if you could kiss her and she
said yes
so people have read my lips
that's clear that's on the video
and I'm going to maintain the same line
that I have given for the past three
weeks
Jenny hermoso in a live Instagram
broadcast from the dressing room said
yeah it happened the kiss but I didn't
like it
you're her boss you're the boss of the
Spanish Football Federation well
technically you are
[Music]
not Instagram live we also see that you
say that you want to marry Jenny when
you go to Ibiza which may be a joke but
also some people may see that and see
that maybe your motives were more than
just friendly no that actually you did
have some sexual motivation otherwise
why would you want to marry her I'm glad
we are here talking in front of millions
of viewers
of course I didn't go on the trip
it was a joke
she has a partner I didn't go to Ibiza
it is impossible that there is anything
there but Lewis you can understand
perhaps that people have watched you
single out Jenny and those are on the
podium for the only kiss on the lips and
then in the dressing room you make a
joke as you say about wanting to marry
her you can see why some people
think hang on a second this is really
inappropriate behavior by the president
of the Spanish Football Federation I
understand that somebody could possibly
misunderstand I also understand that
there are people who understood very
well but Twisted the information
you can imagine if you win the lottery
or hopefully soon one day the war in the
Ukraine finishes I mean celebrations
Will Go On Up and Down The Globe people
don't ask permission it's just a happy
happy time and people celebrate
there will be people Lewis who hear you
say that and say come on you're not
going to seriously be playing the victim
here
what I don't respect is opinions of
people who are trying to twist the truth
my mom is invasive and my dad my kids
were having insultism
these are stand out to be a snowball
created by spurious arguments and people
informatory foreign
my intentions were Noble
enthusiastic
a hundred percent non-sexual 100 I
repeat a hundred percent
so Liz I want to show you another video
this is on the team bus after the
victory
and you see Jenny there a little later
you see the the teammates and general or
mainly the teammates singing there baser
baser Baza Baza which is kiss kiss kiss
and they all seem to be laughing and
finding this funny you're actually at
the back of that of that coach and you
arrive from the back
and they start to charm Prezi Prezi
which is you the president
so what I see is a video whereby the
whole team the staff after having won
the World Cup are having fun I hear the
chanting I hear the chanting pressy Ruby
this app was that my friends use Amigos
I came up to acknowledge I was a little
bit ashamed to be honest and I said I'm
going to go back to the back of the bus
and sit down why were you feeling
ashamed
yes from somebody who was on the bus
this explains what happened
23rd of August three days
I am very thankful to be able to live
one of the best moments of my life with
my family over there is
thanks to you
and also I want to give you all my love
in these difficult times
what we have achieved is amazing huge
and that's thanks to you
don't Cloud anyone's judgment by these
people who want to ruin you
does
so on the 25th 26th this person plus 10
more donde
um wrote a note to say that my Act was
misogynistic
and Pierce is one I have a lot of them a
woman or a man no I'm not going to to he
said it was one of the eleven from a
woman I have for me I understand but on
the particular one you're talking about
if I saw if I saw you other I I'm not
going to I'm going to a criminal court
now you understand but your your point
your point Louis is we don't know who
that is and obviously I can't verify
that but if what you're saying is true
what you're saying is there were people
sending you supportive messages who then
resigned and said what you had done was
outrageous
I don't want to charge but when you have
such a huge current a torrent against
one person it's very very difficult it's
giving me huge problems in life
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean their skin
you believe you can win this war it's
making me cry again I'm trying to force
you out yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katia that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agree to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
hello in Barbie world you weren't asked
to give evidence to the grand jury I'm
the only one that has been telling the
trails you don't drink never taken drug
you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
thank you
[Music]
there are pictures and video footage of
Prince William the Prince of Wales at
the Euros final he is greeting the
England lionesses who won but he's far
more reserved as you wish with hindsight
you would behave more like Prince
William did on that occasion
I'm gonna do
um
so I have a lot of respect for the royal
family I'm not going to enter into
debates about royal family
King Charles years ago I know him I have
apologized for this
I have apologized on several locations
so if you are asking me in hindsight
would I do it differently of course the
intelligent answer is yes of course
the case cause a lot of controversy but
certainly something else you did that
day
you were sitting just a few seats away
from Queen Leticia of Spain and her 16
year old daughter infanta Sophia The
Princess and you very provocatively
grabbed your crotch
in a way that frankly I watched that and
thought that just with members of the
royal family sitting there and a young
16 year old girl again was completely
inappropriate
for this I am truly ashamed more from an
internal perspective than anything else
there are no excuses
in Spain with guys as well as women
there's an expression which would
probably translate to something like oh
my genitals
when the final whistle went Jorge bilda
looked at me and said this is for you
gesture in quite strongly
I adjust your back and said no no this
is for you this is for you for all the
suffering we have had
do you apologize to the queen have you
personally apologized to her no because
I I couldn't have the opportunity to to
speak with
with the queen would you like to
apologize to her now no no yes I did I
did I mean directly to her yes of course
again and all the times and of course
they all the royal family they know me I
I know or King and is a top man and a
spectacular man
um I know him near 15 years ago or 14.
um
I hope they will know
anything is going again anyone but I
apologize because it's not the behavior
I had to to have
your initial reaction on the night when
people started to criticize what you'd
done with the kiss in particular was we
do not pay any attention to idiots and
stupid people it was a pact between two
friends celebrating something that
criticism is really all just nonsense
from and dumbasses these are
just losers who did not know how to see
the positive side do you regret
expressing yourself like that
reflection so I'd like to make a
reflection here regarding my errors
in the beginning I spoke to several
members of the press who said no this is
nothing
no it's just a smaller nectar a trending
topic
no big deal the next day August 21st the
rfef released a statement to the Spanish
news agency efe quoting Jenny hermoso as
saying it was a mutual totally
spontaneous gesture because of the huge
Joy of winning a World Cup the Prezi
rubiales and I have a great relationship
it was a natural gesture of affection
and gratitude
did you know about that statement before
it was made public
yes
uh
she said she never said those things
I have heard it on the radio
so she's lying
no I'm not going to answer that but
there you have the radio you can listen
to the radio yourselves form your own
opinions this isn't good for anybody but
I'm not going to call anybody else
there was as you know a furious response
that built up over the days after the
final
from The Wider football world including
the England lionesses who'd been
defeated by the Spanish team in the
final
every single member of the lionesses
tweeted the following
unacceptable actions allowed to happen
by sexist and patriarchal organization
abuse is abuse and we've all seen the
truth
so once again I'm not going to comment
on third parties but what I want to say
is that this is not a debate about men
or women Progressive or conservative
this is a debate about the truth
so when when the England lionesses every
one of them every woman in that team
tweet that it was abuse and we've all
seen the truth
are you saying they're wrong
I don't want to comment on Fair parties
I don't want any more Wars here
I know the truth I don't want to comment
on that I know the truth in life
mistakes but I'm very calm with my inner
self
what's important to me are the people
close to me and I am very calm about
this is
I want to say that again I made a
mistake I apologize but let's be clear
under no circumstance is this sexual
aggression no abuse
it's an effusive happy moment it's the
same line that I have given from day one
of course
Woody Allen the Hollywood director who's
had his own problems with allegations of
sexual misconduct and abuse which he's
always denied
he came out and defended you
he said the kiss on the soccer player
was wrong
but it didn't burn down a school he has
the duty to apologize and go ahead they
didn't hide he didn't kiss her in a dark
alley he wasn't raping her it was just a
kiss and she was a friend what's wrong
with that
is
two of the only directors that would
direct me to the cinema with my
daughters
not wanting to talk about her parties I
won't comment on this
opinions
just to say that the people who have all
the information not part of it it's
clear there was a mistake but it's also
clear there's nothing more there's no
sexual harassment or violence or
anything like that
Louis you said the at your press
conference on the 25th of August you
said that you were the victim of false
feminists what did you mean by that
what I wanted to do was to focus on my
defense this issue as far as I am
concerned is part of a bigger concert
in my defensive
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
do you have three daughters they're all
quite Young
how difficult has this been for them the
last three weeks well no
um
so I am very lucky I've got three
beautiful mature yes but sensitive
soldiers
I think they are suffering more for me
for my parents than for themselves have
you had some very emotional
times during this period
um
I've had support from my mother my
father cousins nephews nieces
then through the
the it comforts me a lot to the people
the ones I love are close to me and also
people I don't know who come and provide
me with a certain amount of closeness
of course it's very comforting of course
I would prefer not to go through all of
these for sure
your mother went on Hunger Strike she
went to a Catholic church and went on
hunger strike and ended up after two
days being taken to hospital
from the effects of the hunger strike
what was your reaction when she told you
what she was doing
it
I was yesterday with my mother in
Montreal my city my town
I bought her the ice cream that she
loves I spent a little bit of time with
her but it's true that I was very scared
for her
at a certain point her uncle's
completely swelled up she suffers from
hypertension listen we spent a nice
moment did you fear when she was taken
to hospital that you might lose your
mother
that she would give her life for you
well my my mother I
I was thinking see see
he is 72 years old and she has some
problems then she thinks that's probably
she is helping me out
she did no no more words to to play
we've got to a situation now where FIFA
suspended you for 90 days
a letter signed by 81 Spain players
including the entire world cup winning
Squad
was released saying they wouldn't play
until you were gone
they described your actions as violating
the Dignity of women
the letter also included the statement
from Jenny hermoso saying she had not
consented to the kiss or lifted you in
the air
so in regards to the non-consensual the
picking up we have already talked about
that
the FIFA
FIFA
in regards to FIFA with temporary the
process was very very quick
um professor
have been 10 days to reply instead there
was an email
sent to some of the FIFA Executives in
Latin America at five or six in the
morning
so they made a quick decision to suspend
me without giving me the chance to build
the defense objectively I think that was
completely wrong
sing
fundamentos
I am a lawyer I don't understand the
fact that I haven't been able to defend
myself before or after I am a lawyer I
don't understand
I think one of the reasons that you're
in the problem that you're in
is that
your Federation publicly called Jenny a
liar and said you were telling the truth
well in fact it's a complicated
situation with two different
Recollections of what happened and it
may be she's being as honest as you are
in her head about what she felt actually
happened there and it may be you feel
the same way and so there's a
disagreement there but for your
Federation to publicly trash her I felt
that was unacceptable Behavior by the
Federation and if you're Jenny hermoso
you've been humiliated you've been
called a liar to the world and that may
be why she's now taken the further
action that she's taken
so with a judicial review I'm not going
to comment on that I think what's
important is that I focused on what
happened I can't talk about what other
players heard so the manager said
different federations you know it's down
to the judge and what I need to focus on
now is my honor and respect
foreign
the problem you have is that on
September the 8th Jenny Hermosa filed a
formal legal complaint against you which
will now proceed through the criminal
courts alleging assault and there was a
further allegation of coercion with
hermoso telling the prosecutor that her
relatives had suffered pressure from you
and your professional Entourage to say
that she Justified and approved what
happened
what was your feeling when you heard
that she was making him as a criminal
prosecution
I have never pressurized anybody into
anything you categorically deny that a
hundred percent a hundred percent and
nobody in your entourage your team has
put any pressure on Jenny Hermos
I have never pressurized anybody I had
never sent anybody to pressure anyone
there was an allegation that Jorge
Wilder who was the coach of the women's
team who initially supported you he
applauded you when you gave your
statement in public and then said your
behavior was unacceptable and was a
macho attitude there was an allegation
that he had tried to persuade Jenny
hermoso to be supportive towards you is
that true who said this that he had
tried to persuade Jenny Hermosa to be
supportive towards it have you heard
that
no no I don't think
no no chance that Jorge will that
pressure to anybody
there's been a strong reaction from the
Spanish men's players both current and
past issued a statement of solidarity
Hector bellerin he used to play for my
team Arsenal put a statement on
Instagram saying it's truly shameful
what is happening football is a social
tool to advance and progress machismo
should have no place within this system
The Narcissist never believes they've
made a mistake he's capable of lying
very strong words from Hector bellerin
Pierce you can read me 2000 or 2 million
because everybody spoke about it
some of them spoke before to see some
videos and some information others spoke
after other things what they say when
you call by an international player
here's my question when you're called a
lying narcissist who's going after the
victim that's going to hurt isn't it I
mean the international pleasures
read communicate
so so similar if you
comparate that the word I say in the
general assembly that they had a mistake
very big mistake everybody is speaking
do you accept the argument that your
behavior was Macho no and you don't no
my behavior
was inappropriate but no sexual content
no sense Macho doesn't have time hasn't
got to be sexual no yeah but I'm going
to ask you with a question you did me
some minutes ago
about the main team did you do the same
you asked me before what I asked what I
answer you he said you do yes I did when
I was pleasure I kissed
and no two no two come on
two tens of seconds okay more
close do you think Lewis do you think I
can see the impact this has all had on
you
and it's it's a very difficult thing to
be accused of what you've been accused
of
do you feel that now it's become a
criminal matter that this has got
completely out of hand do you think that
is
a massive overreach
foreign
I have been through many processes
criminal as well
and nothing has ever stuck
if you were convicted it's a big if no
no I don't know but if you work in
Victoria well yeah I have to ask the
question okay okay if you were convicted
you would face potentially a prison
sentence
have you thought about that about the
worst case scenario that you might go to
prison for a kiss
I have full faith that the truth will
come out and everything will be fine
but you do not believe in your heart
that you're a criminal
yes
take a look at my face I am a good guy
look at my face look at me in the eyes
the situation of Max happiness rid my
lips Max happiness when a war ends when
you win a World Cup and events like that
it's an amazing feeling it can be
nothing more than complete Joy yeah
do you regret that all the attention
since the Spanish women won the World
Cup has been about you and your behavior
and not the women who won this amazing
tournament
it gives me an incredible amount of
sadness with the job that we've done
we've invested we built a budget from 3
million up to 27 million professionalism
we've got more teams below the national
side it just makes me very very sad when
you played you your nickname was pundino
which is Spanish for Pride because of
your tenacity and hard-working style of
play are you proud of yourself as you
sit here today
when you look back at plant's life a
man's life one mistake can't Cloud
everything that a man does I said I'm
sorry I say that with sincerity
I hope I have some good health and I
have some years left to watch my
daughters turned into fabulous women
you know we make honest mistakes I
haven't made them before
they have always been honest mistakes on
at no staged to hurt anybody you've said
repeatedly that you're sorry for what
you did
but you haven't apologized directly to
Jenny Hermosa
now is your opportunity would you like
to apologize personally to her for the
way she was left feeling about this
so what happens is bad for everyone
we have Journey Lifting me we have the
fleeting Keys two tenths of a second
Alegria
he
what was created from that is crazy
so what's left is for me to Define my
dignity
I understand that but I also understand
that she feels very differently about
what happened
and it seems strange to me that you
would keep saying sorry for what you did
but you won't say sorry to the woman
that you did it to no so it's not about
that piece it's about humility
what we had in the beginning was two
versions that were exactly the same and
therefore an anecdote and now all I can
do is to find the stance that I have had
from the very first day personas
I'm going to try one last time
because you keep saying you're sorry and
you made a mistake and you shouldn't
have done it
but you won't say sorry to Jenny
personally and I'm curious why you're
reluctant to do that
so what we had is a spontaneous act a
mutual active
both consented which was driven by the
emotion of the moment the happiness so I
maintained that that is the truth of
what happened
so again just to be clear no sexual
content and everything that happened was
driven by the emotion
the effervescence of the day and the
happiness
if it was all
as you say
why was it such a big mistake but it
cannot boil dinner because a president
Can't Behave that way towards the
executives at the game on the podium
yes a president can give a hug but needs
to act in a more diplomatic and colder
way
I agree with you
so if you accept that as president what
you did was wrong and it was a mistake
and it was inappropriate
there's only one woman you did that to
wouldn't The Honorable thing as a
gentleman be to say
I'm sorry
um
I have three daughters
[Music]
I have seen the reaction before during
and after
de pues e
Audra persona
it's implemented again I'm going to say
that this was all down to a very happy
moment a celebration a euphoric moment
there was no harm no sexual content no
aggression nothing like that
the significance of the keys to Jenny
would have been exactly the same as a
keys to one of my daughters
between friends and family I understand
but here's what I would say if one of
your daughters ends up playing football
for Spain
and she ends up winning the World Cup
and she goes up to get her medal and
there's a male president
who is much much older
and he grabs her and he kisses her on my
lips and she's the only one of the whole
team he does that to
and he admits afterwards he shouldn't
have done it and it was a mistake
I bet you as the father of your daughter
but the roles reversed a bit would say
he should just apologize to my daughter
again
irrespective of who the father is who
the daughter is to consent in adults in
a moment that was Mutual is
well she lifted me up
where I asked her a question that you
can clearly see
there was no intention
this shows that actually this was just a
mere anecdote is
but you understand she doesn't think it
was consensual I think I answered you
yeah I'm just saying you understand that
she doesn't agree I have my version if
other persons
is not my
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think there's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die Behind Bars and I've
seen your doctor who first raised
concerns about that he wants NHS
managers to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what seven
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board should
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth delay Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know no you're probably going to
vote me off sure
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the trails you don't drink never taken
drunk you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
did you worry that you may lose
everything do you feel a great loss that
you didn't have the love of your parents
sound like my wife how long did he say
you had to live
you've remained extremely loyalty I can
have a friend that 15 other people don't
like I could give what everybody else
and we're going to see Conor McGregor
back Money Changes Everything the
incident on New Year's Eve holy this is
where we're going with this interview
huh
[Music]
all right
you've come under ferocious pressure for
three weeks now on you on family it's
been very difficult for your daughters
their young girls I can only imagine as
a father myself I have a daughter who's
around the age of one of your girls
incredibly difficult
there comes a point perhaps
when the pressure is just so relent
relentless
that you do think about what you should
do
with yourself and your future
many people think you should resign as
president
what are you going to do I love so much
and they they love me so so much I
am very happy and I'm very proud of them
very very proud of them they are very
near
to me about marriage in nation yes I'm
going to do
I'm good you're going to result yeah I'm
going to yes because I cannot continue
my work
for for two or three or three reasons
first of all
I have a suspension
and this suspension is just starting
and is going to continue I'm sure
because if you can see
how it was down
is going to continue
at the same time
I think that the Federation
I it's not a question about if I can
support or know this mediatic tsunami
it's about to know how is going to
affect to the Royal Spanish for
Federation and I love my country and I
love football and I don't want damage
for them
another
I think about it is we
we are running for the World Cup in 2013
we made an incredible
job during the last fun and half
years we started Fernando Gomez
depressing of Portuguese Federation and
me more than five years ago with this
um
I think that
Now is better for this bit
for me to go out and I spoke
no directly but to wherever they are
agree then I cannot be egoist and to
take the chair and not to move myself of
course the situation changed so much
from the moment I say I'm not going to
resign and now saying so so much in
three weeks I don't know is incredible
how
how fast can we some institution what
was the final moment for you was it
talking to your family your dad perhaps
uh yeah my my father my daughters I
spoke with with them
um it's not they know is is not a
question about me and some friends very
very close to me
and they say to me Luis now
you have to focus in your identity and
to continue your life
because
if not probably you are going to that
much people you love on the sport you
love and the bid you build with some
people long time ago now it's very very
near the resolution next September in
one year then when someone is not
thinking only about
himself because I had to support a lot
on this three weeks
but this uh more a question of not only
me
and then an attitude of an attitude of
me can affect
third party is very important and this
is the in this situation now the more
intelligent and the thing I have to do
how do you feel now you've made that
decision to resign it's a huge thing to
do you have the most powerful job in
Spanish football you've loved that job
it should have been the greatest day of
your life winning the World Cup it's
turned out to be the worst day of your
career now you've lost the job that you
love how do you live his life life is
live and we had to to be open-minded
with this and continue
um
not to look at everybody what you had
one thing will come
but and good things for for sure
I'm going to work and I I'm young and I
I only hope to have health
to to be healthy to to be with my family
to work strong
whatever I'm going to do I had some
projects with
some people that were in apart because I
focus 100 of my life in football land
that one kiss Lewis has turned out to
have
pretty horrendous repercussions for you
do you wish you'd never kissed Jenny
Moses could be it could be worse it
could be worse people
um
sometimes has to go
with other more serious things
um
food of all Spanish food or can be calm
with this I always
act with
a honest honestly would you say Louis to
women watching this who may only know
about you from what they've seen that
day and from what they've read since or
seen on television since about you what
do you say to women who think that what
you did was a real affront to women's
football to women
and they look at you and say why did you
do that I'm proud of all my team that
did it possible a lot of people a lot of
women say to me I'm with you
you had a mistake but it's not what
people
say
in some media then be strong we are with
you we are with you and
this is I don't know
I don't want to say a person touch but
I'm
record
Comfort
it sorry but some people support you
here
not sung I think
out of a lot of
but not because they are supporting a
mistake no they censored the mistake of
course
but they support me because this mistake
is not what other people are talking
about it's a mistake that cost you your
job
I think that
when you have a lot of people looking at
you
you have to be excellent
I don't know if 100 of time but in a lot
of time and I I wasn't excellent and
now I had to take a decision and like I
said to you is
to say I don't move
and to complicate the future of some
people on the sports I love and the
institution I love and the thing is
more generous and
have you told your daughters that you
are going to resign
in the moment I finished this interview
well Louis I guess in the end people
will watch the whole interview and
they'll make their own minds up about
what they think of you it is a
complicated issue but I wish you well
I appreciate the interview thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]